STANFORD RAPE CASE?
THIS IS "SPECIAL REPORT."
>> Bret: GOOD EVENING.
WELCOME TO WASHINGTON.
I'M BRET BAIER.
PRESIDENT TRUMP ELECTRIFIED
CONSERVATIVES AT THEIR ANNUAL
RETREAT IN SUBURBAN WASHINGTON
TODAY.
HIS SPEECH READ LIKE A GREATEST
HITS FROM THE CAMPAIGN TRAIL.
TAX CUTS AND THE ECONOMY,
IMMIGRATION AND THE CURRENT
CHART TOPPER, SCHOOL SAFETY.
THE SECOND AMENDMENT AND GUNS.
THE CROWD THERE AT CPAC SEEMED
TO LOVE EVERY MINUTE OF THE ONE
HOUR, 14 MINUTE SPEECH.
PRESIDENT TRUMP UNPLUGGED BUT
BIG POLICY CHANGES ALSO RAN THE
DAY.
CHIEF WHITE HOUSE CORRESPONDENT
JOHN ROBERTS STARTS US OFF
TONIGHT ON THE NORTH LAWN.
GOOD EVENING, JOHN.
>> GOOD EVENING TO YOU.
NO QUESTION THERE WAS A LOT IN
THE PRESIDENT'S SPEECH BUT ONE
CURIOUS OMISSION.
HIS SUPPORT FOR RAISING THE
MINIMUM AGE TO BUY A RIFLE FROM
18 TO 21.
NATIONAL RIFLE ASSOCIATION, BIG
SPONSOR OF CPAC IS FIRMLY
OPPOSED TO THAT IDEA.
BUT THERE WAS ONE PROPOSAL THAT
THE PRESIDENT FLOATED THAT HAD
HIM IN LOCKSTEP WITH HIS BASE
TODAY.
AT THE CONSERVATIVE POLITICAL
ACTION CONFERENCE, PRESIDENT
TRUMP DOUBLED DOWN ON HIS CALLS
FOR QUALIFIED TEACHERS OR STAFF
TO BE ARMED AND TRAINED TO
RESPOND IN THE EVENT OF A SCHOOL
SHOOTING.
>> WELL TRAINED!
GUN ADEPT TEACHERS AND COACHES
AND PEOPLE THAT WORK IN THOSE
BUILDINGS, PEOPLE THAT WERE IN
THE MARINES FOR 20 YEARS AND
RETIRED.
PEOPLE IN THE ARMY, THE NAVY,
THE AIR FORCE.
THE COAST GUARD, PEOPLE THAT ARE
ADEPT, ADEPT WITH WEAPONRY AND
WITH GUNS.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP INSISTS THAT
THE GUN-FREE ZONES THAT DESCRIBE
MOST AMERICAN SCHOOLS ARE AN
INVITATION FOR KILLERS TO
POUNCE.
AND THAT THE BEST WAY TO DETER
SCHOOL SHOOTINGS IS TO LET
POTENTIAL KILLERS KNOW IF THEY
ENTER, THEY WILL BE MET WITH A
HAIL OF RETURN FIRE.
>> IT'S CONCEALED!
SO THIS CRAZY MAN WHO WALKED IN
WOULDN'T EVEN KNOW WHO IT IS
THAT HAS IT.
THAT'S GOOD!
THAT'S NOT BAD.
THAT'S GOOD.
AND A TEACHER WOULD HAVE SHOT
THE HELL OUT OF HIM BEFORE HE
KNEW WHAT HAPPENED.
>> THE PROPOSAL WAS MET WITH
DIRISION BUT A FREQUENT CRITIC
OF THE PRESIDENT.
>> COCKPIT LUNACY IS THE WAY TO
DESCRIBE THE IDEA OF ARMING 10%
TO 40% OF ALL THE TEACHERS IN
THIS COUNTRY.
>> FROM THE PRESIDENT OF THE
TEACHERS UNION YESTERDAY,
TEACHERS DON'T WANT TO BE ARMED.
WE WANT TO TEACH.
NO AMOUNT OF TRAINING CAN
PREPARE AN ARMED TEACHER TO GO
UP AGAINST AN AR-15.
ON HIS WAY TO CPAC, PRESIDENT
TRUMP WAS ALSO CRITICAL OF THE
BROWARD SHERIFF'S DEPUTY WHO
STAYED OUTSIDE DOUGLAS HIGH
SCHOOL INSTEAD OF RUNNING
TOWARDS THE UNFOLDING CARNAGE
INSIDE.
>> THAT'S THE CASE WHERE
SOMEBODY WAS OUTSIDE, THEY'RE
TRAINED, THEY DIDN'T REACT
PROPERLY UNDER PRESSURE OR THEY
WERE A COWARD.
IT WAS A REAL SHOCK TO THE
POLICE DEPARTMENT.
>> ANOTHER REASON THE PRESIDENT
SAID TO HAVE TEACHERS DEFEND THE
STUDENTS BECAUSE THEY ARE FAR
MORE INVESTED IN THE CHILDREN'S
WELFARE.
>> THESE TEACHERS LOVE THEIR
STUDENTS AND I'D RATHER HAVE
SOMEBODY THAT LOVES THEIR
STUDENTS AND WANTS TO PROTECT
THEIR STUDENTS THAN SOMEBODY
STANDING OUTSIDE THAT DOESN'T
KNOW ANYBODY AND DOESN'T KNOW
THE STUDENTS.
>> IN ADDITION TO SCHOOL
SHOOTINGS, PRESIDENT TRUMP TODAY
ZEROED IN ON ANOTHER THREAT.
ANNOUNCING THE BIGGEST PACKAGE
OF SANCTIONS YET AGAINST NORTH
KOREA TARGETING 27 COMPANIES, 28
SHIPS AND ONE INDIVIDUAL FOR
SMUGGLING FUEL AND OTHER
SUPPLIES TO SUPPORT NORTH
KOREA'S NUCLEAR WEAPONS PROGRAM.
APPEARING IN THE EAST ROOM WITH
AUSTRALIA'S PRIME MINISTER,
PRESIDENT TRUMP ISSUED ANOTHER
SHARP WARNING TO NORTH KOREA.
>> THE SANCTIONS DON'T WORK,
WE'LL HAVE TO GO PHASE TWO.
AND PHASE TWO MAY BE A VERY
ROUGH THING.
MAYBE VERY, VERY UNFORTUNATE FOR
THE WORLD.
>> WITH TODAY THE DAY A NUMBER
OF WHITE HOUSE STAFFERS WERE SET
CLEARANCE, PRESIDENT TRUMP
WEIGHED IN ON THE FACT THAT
SON-IN-LAW JARED KUSHNER IS
STILL OPERATING WITHOUT HIS FULL
SECURITY CLEARANCE.
>> WE INHERITED A SYSTEM THAT'S
BROKEN.
IT'S A BROKEN SYSTEM.
AND IT SHOULDN'T TAKE THIS LONG.
SO THAT WILL BE UP TO GENERAL
KELLY.
GENERAL KELLY RESPECTS HIM A LOT
AND GENERAL KELLY WILL MAKE THAT
CALL.
I WON'T MAKE THAT CALL.
I WILL LET THE GENERAL WHO IS
RIGHT HERE MAKE THAT CALL.
>> SOURCES TELL FOX NEWS TONIGHT
THAT THE DEPUTY ATTORNEY GENERAL
ROD ROSENSTEIN TELEPHONED THE
WHITE HOUSE COUNSEL TWO WEEKS
AGO TO SAY THAT JARED KUSHNER'S
NOT BE COMPLETED BY THE DEADLINE
TODAY.
THAT THERE WERE STILL SOME
OUTSTANDING ISSUES THAT REQUIRED
FURTHER INVESTIGATION BUT WE ARE
TOLD TONIGHT FROM WHITE HOUSE
OFFICIALS THAT JARED KUSHNER
STILL MAINTAINS HIS INTERIM
SECURITY CLEARANCE.
BRET?
>> Bret: YOU HEARD THE PRESIDENT
SAYING GENERAL KELLY WILL MAKE
THAT CALL.
THE CHIEF OF STAFF.
ALL THE TALK ABOUT WHETHER
GENERAL KELLY IS STAYING OR
GOING, WHAT IS THE INSIDE
SCUTTLEBUTT?
>> THE INSIDE SCUTTLEBUTT IS
THAT HIS JOB IS SAFE.
YOU KNOW, ONE PERSON TOLD ME A
WHILE AGO THAT YOU HAVE A PLAYER
WHO STAYS OUT UNTIL 4:00 IN THE
MORNING AND YOU BENCH HIM AND
THAT PLAYER WERE TO BE TOM
BRADY, THAT PLAYER WOULD NOT GET